COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of "Cloud Performance Atlas,"
I help some foodies bring
home the bacon by profiling
their startup time.
Can their architecture
stand the heat?
Stay tuned to find out.
I gave a talk in
New York last week,
where I met the people
behind FoodEpix,
a social network
that only allows
you to share pictures of food--
no text, no audio, no emoji.
Just a picture of food
and the geoloc tag
where it was taken at.
Turns out their team had read my
previous articles on App Engine
startup performance and wanted
to reach out and see if I could
help them with a similar issue.
While talking to their team
over a round of free pizza,
I got a clear sense
of their architecture.
As a user uploaded
a picture of food,
it was sent to a Compute
Engine instance, where
it ran some logic and
processing on the picture
to make sure it's
really an image of food.
Now, I didn't really
figure anything was wrong
until they showed me a
graph which looked something
like this.
They were seeing about
300-second cold boot
time for their applications
while the response
latency for a request was in
the 300-millisecond range.
Now, to be fair, by this
point I hadn't really
dug in to Compute Engine cold
boot performance that much.
So I was happy to use this as an
excuse to investigate further.
Now you may see a common trend
in my performance debugging
pattern at this point.
When trying to track down
performance issues like this,
I first like to remove my
code and establish a baseline
to know how badly my
code is impacting things.
As such, the first steps
in figuring out the problem
was to run a quick test to
see if, number one, given
a static configuration, how long
Compute Engine instance takes
to boot up, and number
two, given changes
in that configuration,
how does that
impact the previous number?
So, let's start
with a simple test--
just 15 iterations of starting
an instance and timing how
long until we can SSH into it.
On average, a two-CPU, 8-gig
VM took about 60 seconds
to boot up, which I think does
a nice job of establishing
our baseline.
Now, I would assume that
improving resources should
see an improvement
in cold boot time
since there's more cycles
available to help the image get
up and running.
So I doubled the
core and memory count
and saw an average
of about 63 seconds.
A little worse, but still
within margin of error.
This made me wonder if
increasing the CPU and RAM
caused boot time to
degrade linearly.
To test that, I
increased both by 8x
and saw that the average
time was about 62 seconds.
Which doesn't exactly
conform to my thought
that VM startup time would be
linear with resource requested.
More so that these
timing fluctuations
had something to do with the
small size of my sample set.
That being said,
GCE did recently
update the max number of CPUs
you can request in a VM to 64.
And when testing, we
did see that these
had consistently
higher cold boot
time than their less than
32 core counterparts.
So, just to make sure we
wrap this all together,
let's do 200 configurations
of random CPU and RAM sizes
and see what we get.
After testing this
about 20 times,
the average still looked
to be about 62 seconds.
And to be clear, those
valleys and spikes
don't correlate with a
specific configuration.
They move around
pretty regularly
between iterations of the test.
This whole thing let me
know two important facts.
Number one, cold boot
time of Compute Engine VMs
are not correlated with CPU/RAM
configurations directly.
And number two, the
300-second cold boot time
that the FoodEpix
VMs were seeing
is being caused
by something else.
So, let's get some more
information about bootup.
Now, obviously,
we need to install
the operating system on the VM.
Maybe we were using some
weird configuration of image
that I wasn't testing with.
So, let's put them head to head.
Keep the configuration the
same, but test a Linux instance
versus a Windows
instance and see
if that could be the problem.
Not surprisingly, there was
some variation in the results.
Most of the Linux-based
builds acted pretty similar.
But the Windows builds
were drastically slower.
And, just to get
visibility, I also
tested booting
clusters of machines.
So seeing how one VM booted
versus 20 at the same time
showed some big differences
with the Windows VMs.
But FoodEpix wasn't
using Windows VMs.
They were using Linux
VMs, and only launching
about one or two at a time.
So the choice of an image
isn't having anything
to do with their slow
cold boot performance.
Now, one nice side effect
of profiling things
is that you typically
end up learning more
about some part of the system
that you didn't have visibility
to before.
Or, rather, you end
up adding transparency
to a previous black box system.
For me, running these
tests showed off
a few parts of the system
I didn't know about.
Namely, that Compute Engine
has a distinct latency
in various stages of
VM bootup process.
As a request comes in to
create a new instance,
GCE will move through the stages
with variants' latency attached
to it.
Just to kick the tire,
I enlisted the help
of fellow Cloud DA Terry Ryan.
And I was able to
get a profile on each
of these stages,
which actually didn't
reveal any specific problems.
Other than the specific
startup process,
you can expect about
seven seconds dedicated
to responding to a request
and about 18 seconds dedicated
to provisioning the VM
before any of your code
starts running.
Now, at this point,
it's unclear what's
causing FoodEpix start
time to be so slow.
But, we have eliminated CPU/RAM
configurations and image
selection as culprits.
Sadly, though, I only
have so much time
in each one of these videos.
So if you want to see
what solved the problem,
check out the rest of the "Cloud
Performance Atlas" content.
And remember, when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]